what makes a street a Street and an
Avenue and Avenue they're not just named
it random there's no rulebook for
building a city but there are naming
conventions that are surprisingly strong
ones you'll find across the world there
are exceptions but if you comb through
postal service guides State Department's
of Transportation in dictionaries you
can start to decipher a code behind our
roads
it starts simple a road can be anything
that connects two points away is a small
side street off of a road but then
things build up streets are public ways
that have buildings on both sides and
you'll recognize them because they often
run perpendicular to avenues which will
have trees or buildings on both sides to
the cardinal directions north south east
or west vary by city but that
perpendicular pattern of streets and
avenues is common to a lot of places
this is a Boulevard a big wide street
with trees on both sides you'll find a
median in a lot of boulevards too it's
basically the opposite of a lane which
is a narrow road often in a rural area a
drive takes its cues from the
environment it's a long winding road
that might have its route shaped by a
nearby mountain or lake that might lead
to a terrace a street that follows the
top of a slope a place however is a road
or street with no Thruway basically a
dead end
meanwhile a court will end in a circle
or loop without a third way it's like a
cousin to a Plaza or square in open
public space that's surrounded by
businesses or streets in all of these
roads connect to the wider world a
frontage road or access road or service
road runs parallel to a larger Road
providing local access that larger
public road might be a highway a major
public road that connects larger cities
an interstate is part of a highway
system but it's defined by being a
federally funded network of roads it
often goes between States but it doesn't
have to Hawaii has interstate h1 and you
don't want to take an interstate to get
a Turnpike is part of a highway but it
usually means you'll hit a toll booth
while a freeway is distinguished by size
with two or more lanes on each side a
Beltway meanwhile is a highway that
surrounds a whole city like a belt a
Parkway is a decorated public road
usually called that for the parkland on
the side of the road want to know why
you drive on a Parkway and park on a
driveway Parkway's were originally more
pastoral and they had that parkland on
the side in driveways were often longer
making them ways off of drives a
junction is where two roads cross in an
interchange it's at a different height
while at an intersection it's at the
same height cause ways are different
race roads that pass across low or
swampy ground for water and the rest of
the most common roads are the odds and
ends crescents are winding roads that
usually resemble well a crescent and
often attach to a road at both ends an
alley is a small pathway between
buildings which might not be drivable
and then there's an Esplanade a long
open path or road near the ocean that's
also called a promenade if it's
primarily for walking all these names
aren't there to confuse us but to make
roads and cities clearer and now you
won't just know where you are but how
you got there - so these street naming
conventions are just that they are
conventions they are not hard and fast
rules and there are plenty of exceptions
and that is the case in Tucson Arizona
because in Tucson the streets run
east-west the avenues run north-south
and something called the Strava new
postal abbreviation Stra runs diagonally
[Music]